ucrania comienza una de las noches más
tensión antes de que comenzó la guerra
mañana es 9 de mayo el día que rusia
celebra esa victoria contra la alemania
nazi en 1945 con un gran desfile militar
en moscú que se esperan declaraciones
del presidente vladimir putin y la
atención es mayor y los enfrentamientos
se hacen también mayores especialmente
en esta región del donbass donde nos
encontramos hoy hicimos un recorrido que
nos llevaba hasta la ciudad de lichis
anc una de las más grandes de la
provincia de lugansk y lo que nos
encontramos fue ataques permanentes
tanto de artillería como de bombardeos
no pudimos llegar porque la carretera
está siendo atacada constantemente
especialmente en el área de una
refinería que no está activa hace dos
años y nos decía el gobernador de la
provincia que no entendía por qué
seguían atacando a esta refinería sin
embargo está también en las proximidades
de esta población débil logarítmica
donde en ese momento 60 personas están
atrapadas en el sótano del colegio y no
se conoce su destino 27 otras personas
que estaban allí en colegio pero no en
el sótano pudieron huir o pudieron ser
evacuadas no se tiene la claridad pero
si se sabe que las tropas rusas tienen
esta población totalmente asediada es
casi imposible entrar a hacer un
reconocimiento de qué pasa con estas 60
personas lo que nos encontramos en la
carretera fue varios grupos de militares
numerosos grupos de militares esperando
entrar a esta provincia mientras que era
atacada y lo que sí también pudimos ver
es grupos de militares llegando heridos
a uno de los principales hospitales de
la región confirmando lo que nos decían
varios testigos de estas batallas y es
que las muchas poblaciones están por el
piso y los ataques cada vez son más
potentes